SPEAKER 1: Google
Cloud Next 2017
featured a rich variety of talks
detailing the future of cloud.
If you didn't get a chance to
catch the "Location-Powered,
On-Demand Economy,"
then stay tuned,
because here's the recap.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: Powered by smart
phones and the ability
to determine location,
the on-demand economy
reflects a significant
shift in user behaviors
and expectations.
SPEAKER 1: As a result, we've
seen significant disruptions
in many traditional businesses.
For example, we used to
hail a taxi on the street.
Now we can request a car
from an app on our phones.
Or consider that eating
restaurant food at home
was limited to take-out
or pizza delivery.
Today, we can get anything
from fresh ingredients
to meals from just about
any restaurant delivered
within the hour.
It's important to note
that these new business
models are driven by
location-powered technology.
Customers request
cars or place an order
on their apps that indicate
their current location.
Meanwhile, the fleet of drivers
and delivery people fulfilling
those requests are constantly
using location-powered apps
to figure out how to
get to their customers.
SPEAKER 2: For example,
traditional taxi and delivery
drivers had to memorize
routes and locations
to efficiently
navigate their cities
without digital assistance.
But with real-time navigation
and routing technology,
this need for
specialized knowledge
is removed, enabling businesses
to significantly increase
their fleet of drivers
with less training cost.
Now you can include
those same features
within your own apps using
the Google Maps APIs, which
are available on Android, iOS,
web, and HTTP-based services.
These APIs give you the
power to do everything
from visualizing points on a
map to routing and planning
for deliveries to preprogramming
television remotes based
on their physical location.
SPEAKER 1: In
order to understand
how to take best advantage
of these features,
let's focus on user
habits and expectations.
Constant technology
advancements have
led to the user expectations
of continuous improvements
in speed and convenience.
We expect our web
pages to load faster,
our movies to be
higher resolution,
our deliveries to
arrive within minutes,
and our phones to not only tell
us how to reach a destination,
but also to navigate around
accidents or bad traffic.
In terms of services,
that translates
into expectations for
continually improving
simplicity and predictability.
Sadly, one caveat with
this economic trend
is that while user expectations
for simple and convenient
services is on the
rise, willingness
to pay for them
is on the decline.
For example, cheap fixed
price physical deliveries soon
became unlimited free delivery.
And low prices for
digital goods quickly
evolved into unlimited plans
for music video and mobile data.
With service
expectations increasing
and consumer willingness
to pay decreasing,
the challenge for
companies is to find
ways to deliver
efficiencies of scale that
will enable the margins
that they need to thrive.
SPEAKER 2: The issue with
location-based systems
is no longer the logistics
in managing a fleet,
deploying it, or even
getting to the last mile.
Instead, the
challenge has shifted
to the last tenth of a mile.
For example, it's not enough
to just go to an address.
You now have to find a
specific person standing
on the corner of that address.
The result is that the
new location-based economy
isn't really about location.
It's about places.
The concept of a place
is important to consumers
on the move.
People want to know that before
they head out to a restaurant,
is it going to be busy?
Is it open right now?
Or is it even worth going to?
While the previous
location-based data changes
slowly--
months at a time--
this new location
economy is filled
with information that's dynamic,
affected by the time of day,
traffic, local events, and even
changes in a business location.
SPEAKER 1: Keeping up with
all of these changes yourself
globally is really hard, which
is where Google can help.
The Google Maps
team is committed
to finding creative
solutions to help developers
like you find efficiencies
in the last tenth of a mile.
The result is that our Mapping
APIs return up-to-the-minute
data that reflects the dynamic
nature of the location-powered
economy.
Check out the full
recording of this session
to see more examples
of location,
the on-demand economy,
and what the future holds.
And of course, if you want more
recaps on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the next
world tour coming soon
to a city near you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]